thanks Joel thanks for overly kind words
and thanks for y'all for letting me be
here today as Joel mentioned I'm one of
about 200 four-star generals and I'm
assured I'm in the top 196 I want to ask
you to do something for me though I've
gotten to speak since I retired at some
amazing places and I went to uh to the
UK and spoke at Oxford and that's an
amazing experience so I went in and they
took me in a historic room a lot of
polished wood and stuff like that and
but right before you go in they show you
a picture of Teddy Roosevelt speaking
right from where you're going to speak
just to remind you you're not Teddy
Roosevelt so I go in to speak and I've
I've done a little bit of prep and I
think I'm going to do pretty well but
right in front of me as soon as I
started talking a person falls asleep
and if you've ever tried to speak
publicly and right in front of where
your gaze is persons almost snoring it's
really distracting so I don't think I am
invited back
so and that was Annie my wife so
if anybody here could help me just kind
of poker if you see or not enough that
would be good but you know she's been
special to me and and as Joe mentioned
you know go through a military career
there are points in life that are pretty
pretty big deals and for in the Army
when you get selected for brigadier
general when you're promoted to that
it's a big step get about 24 25 years in
service it's a big step and it's
designed to pump your ego up and I was
assistant division commander for an old
friend of mine so I'm in this ceremony
with my parents president Annie's
parents president bunch of friends an
old friend of mine pens it's general
Starr on me so I am feeling very good
about me and so I slide up next to Annie
and I go Annie in your wildest dreams
did you ever think you'd be standing
next to me as a brigadier general and
she said Stan you're not in my wildest
dreams so yeah so my ego is well in
check and it's it's right there so
thanks thanks very much for letting me
be here what I thought we talked about a
little bit today is leadership because
it's something that we all know a lot
about we all know most of the right
answers but we as a group and as a as a
nation tend to struggle getting the
answers right so sometimes we got to sit
and look at very strong statements a lot
of people say this now and if you
believe that whether you do or not
you'd have to believe this and then we
got to look inside because we go okay
what would cause that why would that be
the case or is that really true now
we're great leaders but then you look at
some of the things that have happened
over the last even decade some of the
challenges we face and you ask whether
we've as effectively dealt with them as
we would like to and it's arguable
whether we did so you come to the
question okay why have we gotten stupid
have we gotten lazy if we gotten selfish
what has caused us to be so
concerned about the level of leadership
in America and I've got a few thoughts
first off I don't think we've gotten
stupid I don't think we've gotten soft I
don't think we've gotten of bad
intentions I think we still want to lead
well but I think what has happened is we
had many many years in which one model
in one style of leadership was rewarded
with success the things that worked well
worked well for generations and so they
were reinforced by people wanting to use
those more and that's natural you do
what works but in fact as things start
to change sometimes you find they don't
work as well sometimes you get more
competition we do as Tom Friedman will
tell you about the world being flat it's
much closer than it used to be we're not
competing with the people next door
we're competing with everyone now also
things happen faster we communicate
faster it all goes at a speed you can't
be in a front office and let things come
up at the speed of paper through a
bureaucracy and be relevant anymore
they're more complex they've always been
more they've always been complex but I'd
argue it's probably more than ever and
you know when you tell everybody to do
something if you're the great leader in
the front office they don't always do it
with quite the speed or dedication that
you wish they were the discipline of a
lot of things in our society look at our
political parties don't respond like we
think they did or like we think they
should and so what I think we've got now
is a gap we had a very successful model
or at least it was successful for many
people and suddenly we've got a
requirement that's different from what
we had and so it's not working so well
now this was something that I think I
personally experienced in my career in
the military and so maybe I can put it
in that context for me where it began
in April of 1980 I was a young Special
Forces officer green beret in Thailand
and thousands of miles away from where I
was something happened that changed the
rest of my career I had no idea at the
time that it would
what occurred was in the deserts of Iran
a mission called Eagle Claw which was
President Carter's directed rescue
attempt to bring Americans captured held
hostage in the American Embassy in
Tehran failed and it failed very
publicly unveiled a fully what happened
was the raid force went in and two
groups that went in and helicopters and
went in in c-130 aircraft and on the
ground the helicopter maintenance got to
the point where they had to abort the
mission and that was disappointing then
as they were moving to pull that force
out a c-130 fixed-wing aircraft and
helicopter collided produced a fireball
killed eight Americans and caused the
mission to have to be aborted of course
publicly now the tragic loss of life the
failure of an American mission to bring
Americans home and put this in context
for you this was about five years after
America had pulled out of Vietnam in
great frustration and it was four years
after Israel had pulled off the raided
Entebbe with tremendous success so what
happened was you had America the forces
that I was a part of called to do a
national mission and end in failure it
was extraordinarily important it was
extraordinarily important not just
because what happened because what
people did about it to a degree I would
argue that you had that mission been
successful America's Special Operations
Forces now what you read and see so much
about wouldn't be what they are because
people would have been satisfied with
the status quo instead what happened in
that community is people said never
again will never be called on and not be
able to do what the nation asks us to do
and needs us to do and so a change began
and it started by taking some units
which is existed in some units which
were stood up very specialized forces
like the seals Rangers etc and those
forces were honed for the missions that
people thought were going to be required
and very quickly they became world class
I mean they became as
good or better than what anyone had in
the world and they became successful in
a number of places around the world
Panama Grenada other places they had
extraordinary success in doing what the
nation asked but they were also
stove-piped they tended to grow
separately and when they grew separately
as a lot of cohesive organizations do
they tend to become a bit tribal I mean
look at any organization that's got
great pride in itself any team in a
university any element fraternity it
feels great you tend to become so
cohesive that nobody's quite as good as
you and so you're not really comfortable
dealing with anybody but you and so we
had this very effective but very tribal
organization and to solve this problem a
headquarters is created called Joint
Special Operations Command and this was
to create a team of teams to take these
organizations that make him into a
cohesive organization that could do
whatever the nation did it was very very
affected extraordinarily so but it was
also narrowly focused it was designed
for hostage rescue it was designed for
going after people like the Palestinian
Liberation Organization very finite
challenges to specific problems that the
nation faced and that was fine until
things changed actually things changed a
bit earlier than we think on 9/11
because although a lot of people don't
realize it al Qaeda declared war on the
United States in 1996 most Americans
didn't know that most Americans think it
began with the attack on the World Trade
Towers on September 11th but in fact we
had a different challenge in the world
lots of causes for it room for about
three more long-term discussions but it
was a different requirement for a forced
design for counter-terrorist operations
suddenly we had something that was
culturally different than what we had
faced before
and it was difficult to understand it
didn't have a
finite doctrine that was as clear as
some of the previous organizations that
we'd structured ourselves against and
with geographically dispersed it
wouldn't in one place it was in a bunch
of places and it moved around all the
time it also had a tendency to change
everything it did would be for a very
short period of time if you dealt with
al Qaeda and associated movements one
month three months later it was
extraordinarily different and so you had
to constantly update your thinking on
how you dealt with it and they operated
differently if you're old enough to
remember or read about the terrorist
operations in the 1970s and 1980s they
tended to be high-profile things like
hijackings or hostage taking and then
there would be a series of demands made
and the demands would say release people
from prison and will release the
hostages or put a certain amount of
money or do something like that this was
an era in which terrorists didn't do
that they made a demand like get all
Western forces out of the Middle East
which was probably here illogical or at
least not going to happen but then
instead of taking hostages and making
demands they simply kill people they
crashed aircraft into towers they blew
things up and then they looked you in
the eye and they said it's a tough world
how do you like that so a very different
challenge faced us so there's a gap
there was a very narrow very effective
focused capacity against a very wide
very different kind of problem and it
took a different approach to deal with
it and the approach is probably pretty
common-sense there were a number of
organizations that had to become a part
of the solution they were a
whole-of-government approach different
intelligence agencies Department of
State FBI and whatnot all had to become
a part of this and partner nations as
well if we were going to understand and
deal with the problem so that's pretty
straightforward just get all of these
entities bring them into a single team
and go accomplish a complex requirement
if you've ever been a part of this I've
never seen that happen much because
that's just not the way people operate
it does on paper it even works on a
keynote slide but this took us several
years to pull off because there was some
real challenges first off we had a
counter-terrorist task force that all
these forces in it and I was a leader
but I wouldn't in command I commanded
the military part of it but everybody
else was there on a handshake so
everybody else was there basically on a
volunteer basis from their organization
or individually she can't tell him what
to do I didn't have statutory control I
couldn't hire him I couldn't fire him I
couldn't give him a pay raise I couldn't
give him a bonus I couldn't do anything
like that so they're there working as
part of this task force but I don't have
the kind of coercive control or
reinforcing things that we normally
attach to management or command and
control so it required us to lead by
influence now if you think military say
well we don't lead by influence we leave
by tell everybody to do this and
everybody does that that's never been
the truth in the military but in this
kind of organization it was particularly
not going to be the truth so you had to
convince people that what they you
wanted them to do was something that
they wanted to do and it was in their
interest and so we came upon something
that was very different from what we
expected the real solution to this was
something we came up with calls shared
consciousness and purpose and if you
think of it I grew up with sort of
barrel-chested big knuckle commandos and
you throw something like that up there
you get your ass kicked you know so you
had to go back and remind them what it's
about because this is what it's about
it's about winning now I'm not talking
just military if you're in a business
it's about winning what you do if you're
an educator it's about educating kids
there's some standard of winning in
whatever you do and that's what it's
about
so the first thing if you think about
with winning its results you got to
figure out what results yard you got
identify them in our case we had to
prevent al Qaeda attacks the second we
had to be effective and that meant for
us very precise operations the kind
you've gotten used to seeing the rate of
the cotton sama bin Laden
extraordinarily effective in its
execution in this case you had to be on
the right target at the right time every
time but suddenly you had to do this not
once every three months you had to do
this ten times a night because it had to
be scalable the size of the problem that
al Qaeda and associated movements gave
us was extraordinarily different than
anything we'd focus before we were an
organization was designed to be a very
deliberate and its planning and
execution then very successful but
instead suddenly we had to do that on a
speed that didn't allow you to have
centralized control of operations in the
way that you were used to this is one
month in Iraq October 2007 that is just
key leaders captured or killed the scope
of violence at that point in Iraq was
such that that level of effort was
required so how do you get there how do
you do that the solutions pretty clear
in a very complex constantly changing
environment you got to be operating at
the highest level ever faster than
anyone ever even thought about so how do
you get that mission statement from
somebody do ColdFusion by morning so
what's that the approach to fixing this
how do you get there this is the first
reflexive way most organizations that
ours did we're going to do what we
already do we're just going to do it
better we're going to become the best
shots the best pilots the best
everything and we're going to execute so
well and we're going to work harder than
ever before the problem with this is
there is a limit to physics you can get
better and better and better at a
certain point you can't get that much
better than the assembly line can't get
that much more efficient and faster some
other way has got to be found and this
is what we came up with shared
consciousness and purpose we didn't put
it in a big fuzzy red ball for obvious
reasons and so we spring this on people
and this is great because you know
that's the obvious answer right and then
that's the obvious question I got it
boss will do that and oh by the way what
is it so what do we think it is this is
what we think it is or what I think it
is it's everybody understanding
everything obviously that's an
unattainable standard but everybody
having all the same information not to
draw the same conclusions but so that
everybody has all the pieces of the
puzzle and the combined wisdom gives you
the opportunity not to be dependent upon
a single person or a few people to
direct this organization and then the
second part of it is all these people
across the organization feel like they
own the mission if you ask people what
their mission is it's not hey I'm here
cutting this stone it's I'm part of a
team building a cathedral and it's
really a big change in many
organizations and it was a big change in
our organization so we came up with
really break it in into three parts the
first was designing it that's
understanding what you're doing we'll
talk quickly about it what executing and
how do you actually do it that's where
most organizations struggle and then
finally leading it because that's the
most important but the most difficult
part
so think about defining winning we went
to Afghanistan in the fall of 2001 we've
been there ever since and yet if I asked
every
one in this room what the definition of
winning in Afghanistan is we probably
get many many different answers when I
went there in the summer of 2009 to take
over I had different mission statements
from different headquarters I was a NATO
general I was a US commander and I had
two different mission statements which
is great just pick the one you want
you're always going to be in trouble so
you got to define winning and then the
second is you got to align your strategy
and we had 46 nations in Afghanistan the
bottom line is everybody's got to
understand not just where you're going
but how you're going to get there and if
you think about any organization if you
don't have an agreement on how you're
going to get there you're going to
struggle enroute and then defining team
what's your team for something typically
when we define team we want to say it's
the people who wear the uniform we wear
it's the people who operate in the same
organization it's a people whose
paycheck or signed by the same person
people in the same school same hat same
sweatshirt you name it but I'll argue
that's way too small the team is
whatever community is required to get
the task done so if you think about it
the team required to put this talk on
today the business school obviously me
somebody had to get me here somebody had
to turn the lights on somebody's got to
produce the power for this somebody's
got to do all the different parts I'd
argue that's the team and it's much more
complex than you thinking one of the
problems is everybody's got to
understand they're on the team and feel
like a part of it
so unlike just the group that is on the
target all the people the medivac that
people fly in predator UAVs and whatnot
they're just as important as the people
doing the actual task because if they're
not successful the endeavor is not
successful and we've got a reward and
motivate people as part of that wider
team then building a network we talk a
lot about building networks and that's
building typically we confuse that with
just the information technology we build
connectivity to everyone we give
everybody a cellphone iPad computer
whatever's we're going to use and we say
okay
we've got a network well in reality
you've got the potential for a network a
network is that connection that actually
occurs that does something do people
communicate do people collaborate do
people operate more effectively because
of that connectivity and I would say
that that's the goal but they don't
automatically you've got to foster and
force communication this is a picture of
Mike Bloomberg that's where he works in
New York City that's a place called
the bullpen it's a room a little smaller
than this and he sits in the middle he
doesn't have a private office this is a
billionaire mayor of America's biggest
city in end of an office and you go in
and talk to him you say well where do
you really meet people goes right here
and if people want to talk to him they
talk to him right there and it passes
information and it's extraordinarily
effective there is then you got to do
what you say is important we talk about
disciplining prioritizing the effort
this is a tool we used it's a
synchronization matrix the bottom line
is if you take most people schedule and
you say first you ask them what's
important to you in your life or your
job and they list it out then you take
their calendar or their daily schedule
and said where do you actually spend
your time and you'll find we're very
challenged to spend our time against
what we think is important similarly our
money or anything else we've got to
spend our real assets against what's
important to us and it takes rigorous
discipline to make that occur then
you've got to lead this thing you got to
build relationships there's a picture
here of two gentlemen president de Klerk
obviously of South Africa and Nelson
Mandela
now they had two organizations a white
apartheid government and the African
National Congress and they were the
leaders of organizations that didn't
want to come together those two
organizations were polarized and it was
producing violence and was likely to
produce a lot more violence so you had
two leaders who had to make the personal
decision to pull themselves into a
personal relationship at great risk to
themselves politically and even
physically so that their organizations
would be pulled toward the center now my
mind that's leadership right there
because they led not only their
organizations they led the nation but
they did it through a personal
relationship and these are not two guys
who met in a sports bar and hung out one
had to let the other out of prison so
that they could build a relationship
extraordinarily challenging but
extraordinarily important something that
I'm very interested in is he the
American civil rights movement my
family's from the south and I got to
watch it as a boy and it was an
extraordinary strategy this is one of
the few movements that ever followed a
disciplined strategy of non-violent
protest that was successful and it was a
great strategy it was discipline people
but it didn't succeed just because of
that it took an inspirational leader in
fact leaders we think of Martin Luther
King but they're actually more than one
person but it took extraordinarily
inspirational leaders who are willing to
stand up and take that role people who
are willing to realize that leaders
actually lead they don't follow opinion
and then there's a requirement to change
in combat if you don't change you pay a
price if you're at Lehman Brothers and
you don't pay a price you get a
cardboard box so the organization either
learns and adapts or it's gone
so what is this it's shared
consciousness and purpose this is it's
not a cycle that happens in sequence
it's a tide cycle it happens all the
time at the heart of it it's
communication without a doubt it's more
than communication it's really
leadership and then in reality and this
is what scares people when you actually
talk about it it's culture change
because why do people form a culture
because it's comfortable and for them it
works why they defend it because it's
worked for them
so as we go forward to what we call this
now is costly but it's really some
common-sense forms of leadership now I
want to talk just about a few leadership
intangibles and then we'll open it up
for discussion because there's an awful
lot of this that is enduring but it's
worth talking about
that's my only Roman poet quote it's the
only one I know but it's also important
because if you think about leadership
think about people who've actually
experienced it and had challenges if
someone's cruised on to success from
birth they're probably not going to have
learned as much along the way as someone
who's had to climb over a number of
things in business politics you name it
so let's talk about some of these first
is your personal interactions you are as
a leader extraordinarily important you
don't think of it we're not raised to
have big egos when I was young I never
thought I would thought of myself as any
other of the knuckleheads and I was and
I still am but when I was a battalion
commander I used to write personal notes
and one time I wrote a note to some
wives in the unit that Annie had
recommend I do because they've done a
lot of good work for it and went over to
their quarters and one of the notes was
framed it was a handwritten note just
thank you note and they had it framed on
the wall the wife did and you suddenly
realize how important thanking people
are is and how important you as a leader
can be you can have that impact
it doesn't mean you think you're a cool
person but it does mean you can touch
people and you should do that so every
time you have interactions you've got to
figure out how can I get this right and
you may have 150 in a day and if you're
a senior leader for me the litmus test I
always told people was if you talk to
someone and they're going to go home
that night and tell their spouse about
the conversation then you're a senior
leader and every comment you make to
someone matters because if your flip or
you're tired or you're cranky or
whatever they're going to go home and
tell their spouse that but if you're
positive and upbeat and and do the kinds
of things you want to do as a leader
they're going to do that
and that's what you want to be but your
interactions are hard I remember
standing next to that the hospital bed
in the center and that young Afghan
soldier had lost both legs and guess
what he's not going to get the kind of
medical care there that we give our
veterans here he gets pretty good
medical care but then he goes back out
into society he doesn't get the kind of
prosthesis that we would give our forces
because they can't afford it this kid
asked me if he could we could get him
legs so he could go back into the fight
so your personal interactions not only
affect them
but if you're human affect you then
there's time and energy management you
only got a certain amount these are two
brothers that work for me for a number
of years this is their typical pose
there's only so much of you and you
can't create anymore
you can't drink energy drink and get
three more hours out of the day you can
try that for a while but pretty soon
what you'll find is you run out and the
people around you fall down so suddenly
you got to do a couple things one you
got to realize you're human and the
second you got to realize the people
around you were human and you've got to
take care of them just like you take
care of yourself obviously I did a good
job of them you're going to work up and
out as well we all get very comfortable
dealing with the people that work for us
because they typically are going to be
cheerier and more pleasant to us because
we pay them or we rate them or whatever
but you're going to have to work up and
out in many cases as you get more senior
the most important thing you do for the
people below you is to work well with
the people above you and you owe it to
them you owe it to your bosses and your
peers to keep them informed to develop
the kind of relationship but every once
in while you owe it to them to just
reach up and say hey thanks you're doing
a good job and we think of that as being
a sink of fat or sucking up now
sometimes it's just senior people
supporting each other because if unless
you're not human you're going to need
that people ask me when do I lead by
example I'll tell you you're leading by
example
every moment of every day either a good
example or a bad example but you are
people watch everything you do they
don't watch just when you're up on stage
given the talk they watch everything
else if you double park your car out
there when it's not allowed come in and
give a great talk and then other people
say that that's going to get out there
and pretty soon that's going to be that
sucker ooh double parks hugely important
the guy on the left I was talking to a
British NCO they had just gone into the
Helmand River Valley summer 2009 had
lost his brother a few months prior in
Iraq when I was there and so is your
dealing with people like that yours
you're showing them not just that you
care but you're showing you're willing
to be in Helmand with them you're
willing to be there when it's late when
it's dangerous when it's cold whatever
it is people don't like you're willing
to do that and then inclusion what's
most important I played junior varsity
basketball when I was in high school at
one point and I was like the seventh guy
on about a 10 or 12 man team but he only
played about six guys so the whole year
I got in the game one time for about 20
seconds I got a shot off and I hit it I
had the highest shooting percentage in
the team so I haven't got any phone
calls asking me to the NBA but but the
funny thing about it is is when we drove
to games I wasn't excited because I knew
I wouldn't get to play and when we won I
wasn't excited or happy and when we lost
I wouldn't upset because I wasn't
invested in it like I wanted to be I
wanted to be desperate I wanted to have
those feelings but I didn't now think
about it in your organization if you
don't share information if you don't
make people feel a part of it are they
going to celebrate the big win I don't
think not unless they're different from
what I was it's extraordinarily
important to make people feel like
they're part of the whole and there are
a lot of ways you can do it but the
first thing is just tell them just bring
them in just trust them just give them
something and then the final is
really leadership during crises if you
haven't had any crises hang on they're
coming you are going to face some and
the problem with the crisis it's not
that it's not like the movie where the
crisis arises and you know exactly what
to do if that happens it's not a crisis
it's the crisis when it arises and you
go holy smoke this has never happened
before what do we do and everybody looks
at you and that's the first thing that
happens everybody looks at you the
picture in the center this was when an
American jet at the request of a
coalition force dropped two bombs on
some fuel trucks had been hijacked by
the Taliban the problem is they were
surrounded by civilians when they
dropped him and about a hundred
civilians were killed nobody tried to do
the wrong thing
was no evil but about 100 civilians were
killed
so we suddenly had a crisis with the
Afghan people we had a crisis with the
Afghan President with a crisis with the
coalition partner who had dropped it
because they were upset and they were
worried about recriminations on
themselves we hadn't levels of crises so
what do you do what I did was the first
thing I did is try to across the force
communicate what's the right thing I
call President Karzai I went on TV and
apologized to the Afghan people I dealt
with the coalition force as openly as I
could but I said we're going to do the
right thing here we're not going to try
to hide it we're not going to try to
shape that it wasn't what it is and the
whole time you try to be the example
because everybody's watching how you
respond everybody watches your body
language whether you're calm whether
you're not and whether you operate from
a moral compass that they want to
believe in because as soon as they see
you cutting corners or shaving edges
your regard even if you get away with it
is gone
so this is what I came to believe people
ask me often whether leadership is
something that's born with or whether
it's taught I think you can teach it the
biggest thing is people just have to
make a decision to be a leader because
the thing about leadership is it's not
that complex but it's really hard I can
tell you all the right answers be a
leader and you won't write them down
because you'll know them all but it's
like knowing the right answer to be in
great physical shape or to be very
well-read or to speak six languages
the difference is just doing it and
that's like we're leadership Falls
thanks and I'll open it your questions
sir hi my name is Vivek I'm an MBA one I
wanted to ask you about you mentioned
time and energy management and I wanted
to ask you about that in the context of
your own personal routine some of us
were talking before the talk we've read
that you only need four hours of rest
each night that you eat one meal a day
so that you don't feel sluggish and that
you run depending on the accounts we
read eight or ten or twelve miles a day
and and we even one of us fred that you
went running with david petraeus a
couple years ago and he learned that he
wasn't the fastest person at that army
base and so what I wanted to ask was you
know what advice did you give to your
the officers who work for you and you
would give for us even though most of us
won't be going into combat situations
about staying fit and healthy and
prepared to take on the task of leading
how we structure our days so that we
don't waste time and get the most out of
every moment in each day that's it
that's that's really great first thing
is you should hire my publicist who
comes up with all that stuff now that
the reality is then you know be very
since I'm among friends here I'll be
very honest um yeah I eat one meal a day
and that's just because I do feel
sluggish fight more net now that meal is
a prodigious proportion it's uh I
describe it as anything I can reach
until I fall asleep
so you know it's just how but I got in
many many years ago and so it's just one
of those things in terms of the amount
of sleep I slept about that because
that's how much time I had if I had more
time I'd be happy to sleep more and I
you know I certainly when I get the
chance to do but I did find out that
that's about the balance that I needed
to at that point to do the things I did
and so what I tried to do was hit a
balance that made me feel right I got up
early in the morning and worked out
because that was important for me to get
the day going then I had some quiet time
alone to work then I did most of the day
and visit troops and all and then in the
evenings I start to fade in energy and
so what I learned to do was put those
things that don't require analytical
thought later in the day I mean guys
would learn not my staff would learn not
to come to me for really good decisions
at night
but I could sign stuff I mean I could do
you know those kinds of things yeah I
mean you got to know your limitations
but I also learned to have people around
me that really understood I was very
transparent about my battle rhythm
strengths and weaknesses that could fill
in the gaps but could also know when I'm
best in the day how much sleep I need I
had a certain you know guy worked with
it just was very protective of that at
times he'd say stop it go to bed you
know that sort of thing is important I
think all those things are really
important on a couple levels one when
you're in an organization people want to
know that you are somebody that they
have respect for I think if your life is
if your health is in a shambles if your
finances are in a shambles if your
personal life Center samples you're not
going to build as much confidence in
them as if you got your act together so
it's just like if they see you cheat on
their tax on your taxes and they wonder
how you're going to deal with them in a
business sense they're going to do the
come you know the calculation if he lies
to the US government you might lie to me
too all those things matter and I think
you don't need to make a big publicity
about it people will watch you enough to
know whether you're you've kept up but
it's not something just for you you owe
it to them Thanks hi sir Rob Simmons
class of 98 company c-2 I'm here in the
ed school and thinking a lot about unit
readiness and how leaders assess their
their collective units and especially
under circumstances where they're doing
something new like a new product or a
new development or in your case you know
a new Afghan unit getting ready to do
something and kind of what are the
metrics and what are your thinking
around that that we can benefit from
yeah I don't know if your benefit from
Rob Thanks the the key thing about
metrics is we tend to measure what's
easy to measure and we tend to struggle
what with measuring the things that
really tell us what we want to what
you're trying to measure in a new
organization is can it do what the
organization is is designed for and so
until you get a chance
to use it you're trying to create the
analog of that and how many ways can you
measure it in military units we would
measure how much equipment they had how
much how many senior leaders do they
have the right number of people they
have the right ranks do they have the
right amount of equipment it tells you
some stuff but it's a predictor but it's
not any guarantee that that organization
can function and so obviously what I
would do is I would you know those basic
ones are pretty empirical I would then
try to develop some tests which tell me
how they do the first would be cohesion
though does that organization can it do
stuff together and so to a degree even
if the organization's task was to do
something you can't measure let's say if
their task is to put out forest fires
but you can't go light forest fires to
check and they can do it I'd go where
you can but but what I would do is I'd
say what do you really need to fight a
forest fire you need people who are
pretty physically fit you need people
who understand the science of it and you
need people who work together as a team
and if I had to go find something that
requires them to work together as a team
and maybe think a little bit in the
process I'd do that some physical things
that you know tasks it goes team sports
I think would be very very good for more
complex things in business you're on
your own Thanks Thank You general for
coming my name is Mubarak Imam and I'm
curious about what actions do you think
the US and Pakistan can take to make
bad-ass on a safer place
that's great one um if if you go back
and you look at the history between the
United States and Pakistan of course
Pakistan formed in 1947 it's been uneven
there's been a series of periods from
Pakistan felt as though they were the
better partner for America during the
Cold War during the 1980s when they were
the conduit for support to the
Mujahideen during 1970 when Henry
Kissinger went through Pakistan in
preparation for the China trip it's at
71 I'm sorry preparation for the China
trip that Nixon took Pakistan felt like
they'd done more than America was doing
in return and then you have it goes turn
about their periods where America
thinks that that America is doing more
in Pakistan is supporting the Taliban or
supporting lashkar-e-taiba you name it
so this huge amount of mistrust I think
the most important thing we can do is
everybody step back and do a reset
people think what's the most important
part of our relationship with Pakistan
and that's al-qaeda and I would argue
it's not al-qaeda matters but if you
look at Pakistan's strategic interests
which are security from India in the
region its economy its management of
water which is a problem its management
of electricity and the fact that
Pakistan has never had a civilian to
civilian government transfer it's always
was at 64 years of history 32 have been
military leadership 32 have been
civilian what Pakistan needs is help
shaping itself for its big strategic
challenges in the world and I'd like to
believe American can be a partner for
that because America benefits from the
the idea of Pakistan being was 170
million people as a stable nation in
that region so I think we've got to
raise the discussion a little bit higher
to the strategic level and we got to
stop poking each other in the eye on
some of the more tactical things there
are different tactical objectives but
the biggest thing is trust I mean we are
at this point now where the deficit of
trust makes everything hard and if we
could work on one thing before we work
on out on anything else it would just be
trust over and over I know it sounds
simple but it's like leadership answers
simple executing it's really hard thank
you ma'am I thank you so much for being
here today
general McChrystal my name is Rachel
Brule I am a PhD student in political
science here and I actually had a little
bit of a chance to observe some of your
great work when I was at Special
Operations low-intensity conflict
working on Afghan reconstruction under
Colonel Dallas
Brown but I had a kind of more
conceptual question to ask you going
back to one of the final themes of your
presentation on the importance of
cultural change
and so I wanted to push you a little bit
more on that and to say when you're
thinking about cultural change that's
not just between individuals so you're
not just talking about leading by
example but you're really talking about
kind of you know group level changes
across groups that you can't in
influence or interact with individually
how do you think you help to bring about
reflection and really fundamental
cultural change
yeah great Rachel I it's tough I've got
Joe filter here you know more about it
than I ever will Joe ran the the
counterinsurgency advise-and-assist team
in Afghanistan and I just listened to
him so that which went well I get credit
for that which would doesn't there's
this kid good know um and that that is a
leadership Maxim I would offer y'all the
first thing you do in any endeavor is
designate a scapegoat you know make sure
it's not you but and it's good if you
tell them in advance so no cultural
change is huge and it's easy for me to
say
the problem with culture is they're
there for a reason look at the u.s.
Civil Rights Movement when the case of
giving all Americans their rights it
wasn't just a case of ok we'll give
everybody their rights the problem is
that comes at someone else's expense
whether it's really them giving up money
or something
no it's given up some people in the
South perceived that they were going to
lose their position in society if
everybody had equal opportunity and so
you have this great why should I buy
into cultural change if my life's going
to be harder or my part of whatever it
is I'm interested is going to be less
and you have to convince people that one
it's typically not a zero-sum game the
place can be better and I think over
time people accept that but but
near-term they have a tough time with it
and you have to make a very cogent
argument that says you won't be
effective otherwise when we made the
argument in Afghanistan to really focus
on counterinsurgency we didn't get
everybody together and say guys this is
the right thing to do because we love
the Afghan people and we want to do the
right thing even though that was true we
the argument was that we'll lose if we
don't do this this is the only way to
succeed and that's interesting because
people drop back and go wow really I say
yeah absolutely
and so then you can push cultural change
if they think that's what has to happen
to move forward you know the South had
to change the Mubarak regime Egypt had
to change but a lot of people serious
has to change but think about it now
there are a lot of groups in Syria for
whom change will be cultural change as
well as political change so they're
holding on very strongly to be expected
so you got to make that argument to them
but then you got to accept that there's
a there's a group of people who are
going to lose equities in the near term
and you have to you kind of have to
power through that it's not going to
most cultural changes not entirely
voluntary on on groups or people's parts
as you know thanks Rachel
that's our ma'am
general crystal thank you so much for
your service to this country and for
being here today my name is Colleen
Mizuki and I'm a member of nascent
Institute looking at innovative ways to
help our veterans after their deployment
to a combat zone and very I think
importantly I also volunteer to work
with soldiers and family members in the
reintegration process so you talked
about you know leadership not being
complex but very hard and I think that
for me what underlines everything you've
talked about and say counterinsurgency
approach in Afghanistan is mindset
change so I wonder if you have some
words of wisdom that I can pass on to
soldiers that I work with in helping
them understand that after very
difficult experiences in combat how do I
how to how can they accept that mindset
change is possible that it's not complex
but it's also not very easy thank you
but that's a great point thanks for what
you're doing yeah
mindset is extraordinarily important
what you do why you did it and what you
did is important and if you think about
veterans sometimes they don't have a
problem going but when we ask someone to
go into the military and go to war what
have we really asked them you say well
asked you to take a job and do whatever
know we've really asked him to believe
we've said we're asking you to push the
ibelieve button in your nation in your
leadership and the fact we'll take care
of you it's a huge leap of faith for a
young person to go in the military and
go forward to combat because the nation
says hey we love you they've they bought
into that they believed now there's the
second part of it I used to go around to
battlefields and places in DC and
whatnot Lightsey monuments and I'd say
wow this is a monument to the ego of the
people who are there and they really
just want their their head padded for
the fact they did that and whatnot
that's not it at all as I got older I
realized that's the opposite of it when
you go to a monument like the World War
2 veterans memorial air in DC what you
really see is of the 8 million Americans
who served in uniform and then all the
families were touched by it you know war
is pretty ugly when you're up close to
it it doesn't feel good it doesn't feel
clean it's war and it's frustrating it
never comes out exactly like you want it
to but at the end of the day what we
have got to reassure people and what
monuments do is they basically tell
people you did what we asked you to do
when the nation asked you to do
something you did that you stood you
served you sacrificed whatever it is we
asked and that's what I think people are
looking for they're looking for some
reassurance that they did what was asked
and when we go to veterans now what what
I think we've got to do particularly you
know these wars aren't particularly
popular you know I'm not that excited
about them but I will tell you what
we've got to do is convince the young
people who suffer from different kinds
of stress or physical industry's
injuries hey thanks you did what we
asked you to do and that's pretty darn
good
and we don't that's got to be totally
separate from all the other things let
me thank everybody for being here today
I really appreciate it
you